It's like the dumbest point in arguing about that.
But this teaching about rebirthing, we should be able to experience it now.
Everything of the Buddha is known as Dita down there.
It's something to be seen here and now.
It's not true here and now, it won't be true in the future.
That's all.
It's as simple as that.
So let's just take the body.
Is it reincarnating?
or is it reverting?
Reincarnation, the word suggests, is the same body arising moment after moment.
Now, I think all of you know that every cell, every atom in the body is replaced every seven years.
That's what they tell us.
So tomorrow, when you look in the mirror, just remind yourself, this face wasn't here seven years ago.
Okay?
Now the fact is that every seven years the phase looks approximately the same.
I mean, it is getting worse, but it looks approximately the same.
So there's a feeling that it is the same phase, but we know it isn't.
It's reverting.
Every cell is reverting in its own way.
Okay?
Every atom.
That's the process of rebirth.
Think about your...
your emotional life.
And when we say the body, by the way, I'm here meaning also the sensations that come from the body, because the body gives us.
So the sight of our eyes probably get a bit weaker as we get older and things like that.
So even though the eyes are reverting, they're also getting worse, but that's the way it is.
But every moment, every moment, you see, you can't say this is the same body as the last.
And yet here it is.
That gives us an idea of the distinction between reincarnation and rebirth.
If we go into the mind, just consider your emotions, your emotional life.
Sometimes peaceful, sometimes not so peaceful.
It's constantly birthing, isn't it?
there's constantly this process of emoting all the time all you have to do is just stop still and place your attention inward and there's some mood there, there's some emotion there but it's constantly changing there's this constant state of rebirthing re-arising into the present moment but it's never the same emotion what about thoughts?
just think about how our thoughts have developed over the years say from the age of two
It's changed, hasn't it?
Hope.
So you can see, we're still thinking, the thought we arrived at, but it's never the same thought.
So now, when we die, well, let's see what happens.
Now the Buddha points out, if we live according to our spiritual aspiration, if we live according
according to goodwill, it generally, it will make our inner life more happy, more settled.
I mean, if you're in a war situation, no matter how much goodwill you are, it's still not a pleasant place to be.
But inwardly, you can begin to have a certain peacefulness about ourselves.
And by doing that, we are forming relationships, so it helps the relationships around us.
So, by practising peace,
By developing spiritually, we're actually making this life, right here and now, something more pleasant for us, more happy, more meaningful.
Now, according to the understanding, we're developing conditionings, these conditionings.
So, if there is no rebirth after death, if we just annihilate, fine, but at least we've had a fairly decent life, I mean, we've been gentle, yeah?
If we happen to rebirth and find ourselves in another place, another time, then these conditionings come with us.
Because you don't arrive there with nothing.
So these conditions come with us and then we'll be very happy that during the last life we did a bit of practice.
So it's a win-win situation.
I think.
But these concerns about rebirth is... What's the point?
Our...
Our attention spiritually, see, from a spiritual point of view, is right here and now.
It's the only moment we've got anyway.
It's this, you know, the whole of our practice, the whole of our effort should be getting this moment right.
There we are.
You talked earlier about... Oh, there's any questions, rather?
I'm sorry, I should... Any...
Criticism?
You talked earlier about the link between identification and the arising of suffering.
Could you say a little bit more about identification as a phenomenon, as a process?
Just for those of you who've been into Buddhist practice for some time, historically speaking, when the Buddha talks, he's very careful to talk about experience.
He's very careful to keep his language mainly about experience.
So when he talks about nirvana, he's talking about an experience.
as Buddhism developed the action changed away from the experience to what is it that experiences the experience and that became what's known as the consciousness only school when we're practicing and we are pulling ourselves out of this body with its sensations when I say that I mean they become objects you can feel feelings
when you pull out of your emotions you've found a position where you can feel emotions you're aware of your emotions all the time this awareness is beginning to disidentify with what it previously would have identified with and this backwards step you see leads to the realisation of what this awareness is
And the word I prefer for that is the knowing, rather than consciousness, because these days that word's been used in all sorts of ways.
The knowing is a rather good word in English, because it's one of these gerunds which has a verbal meaning, knowing, so it doesn't coagulate so much into some thing.
So,
this knowing has the capacity of being aware and it is our intuitive intelligence that's what it is and it's prior to thought
thought isn't intelligence it's prior to thought, it uses thought to express its understanding it's prior to emotion it uses the emotional life to express its understanding and it's prior to the body it uses the body to express its understanding so these are three so-called intelligences our physical intelligence that we see in sport our emotional intelligence and our intellectual intelligence but these are simply expressions
coming from this knowing.
And this knowing becomes more apparent to us the more we distinguish between that which knows, the awareness, the looking, the observing, and what is actually experiencing.
See?
I forgot the question.
Yes?
It sounded like intuition to me, some kind of deep intuition, what you just talked about.
I was down at the dinner table, and there was this pot of hummus, and I wanted to take something inside me and say, don't do it.
And I thought, that's stupid, I really like hummus, why shouldn't I eat it?
And it said, don't do it, and I thought, oh, bother.
And I took my spoon and lifted it up, and the lady across the table
reached over and I smacked the spoon again so I had it on hold for a moment.
So I think I had some intuitive inkling, well I shouldn't do it but I didn't understand it and I didn't listen to it either and yeah, that's kind of stupid.
I'm not sure I would take that as a great example what I would say is that there's a confusion between intuition and the feeling of intuition now you've got to be careful because this intelligence in Buddhist understanding is deluded so you may feel something is right but it's not necessarily so just as we may think something is right and it's not necessarily so everything that we feel and think has to be questioned
Don't think that just because I have a feeling it must be right.
Sometimes these feelings come in other ways, like voices from God, like that guy who went and swam across the lake to say Aung San Suu Kyi.
So you have to be very careful about, you know, the intuitive feeling must be right.
You have to question it too.
Now,
this process of stepping back out of the body with its sensations and so on is the process of disidentification you're redefining yourself I'm not the body I'm observing the body, I feel the body but I am not the body I'm not emotions, I feel them, I know them but I am not that, see?
so you're constantly stepping out of previous identification and as I mentioned I think this morning
the observer is the most difficult one to overcome because you can't step out of that if you step out of that you simply create another observer observing the observer it's a sort of endless mirror process so that is beyond our control that happens when the times are right so every time we
fall into an identification, we become what we identify with.
That's why it hurts.
That's where the suffering is.
So this pain in my knee, so long as I can observe it as pain, so I'm saying pain, pain, see?
And there's this push away from it.
Right?
I don't want to, right?
Now, in meditation, I'm observing this resistance not to be with the pain in an equanimous way, not to open up to it.
And because of that, this begins, this reaction, it's only a reaction, begins to die away, and I find myself peaceful with pain.
This is on the presumption that he is not about to explode.
We're not trying to defeat pain.
We're not trying to be better than pain.
We're just trying to investigate what pain is.
So now this resistance has gone, and I'm sitting just with this sort of ache in my knee, and I'm saying things like pain or aching, you see.
Then, as it were, I drop into the pain, I drop into those sensations.
And as I drop into it, deep into it, I actually begin to feel the sensations, my noting work changes.
I begin to say things like heat or pressure.
And at that point, you see, there's no suffering.
Suddenly, as I move my awareness upwards, as it were, and it becomes pain again, then I get the resistance.
Then I realise that pain is a mental construct.
It doesn't actually exist.
What exists are sensations coming from the knee.
So these are your investigations.
And so, in so doing, you disidentify with the idea of pain.
And that helps you to find an equanimity with it.
Now, as I say, you only do this to a certain point.
That's that.
So, every time we fall into an identification, suffering will come.
Even in everyday life, as soon as you identify with your job, right?
I am a nurse, you know, I am a whatever.
As soon as I am something, there's potential of suffering.
You lose your job, who are you?
Yeah?
You go through an identity crisis.
See?
Rather to say to yourself, this is what I do, rather than this is what I am.
Yeah?
And at the more subtle level, there's the relationship of possession.
See?
When you possess something, you possess people, you possess them.
So that relationship is one where this object, or this person, is being held by you, clasped, grasped by you.
So there there's tremendous potential for suffering.
If the person goes, disappears, dies, whatever, then you're left with this burning ache in the heart, which is that grasping.
If you lose something, you get very angry.
If somebody takes it, you get even more angry.
You know?
And some of you will hear me say, if somebody steals something from you, you still go around saying, you know, they stole my car, they stole my purse.
It's theirs.
Of course.
It's about the living in the delusion.
That is yours.
See?
And as soon as you click onto that, then you see compassion arises.
You say, well, they can have it.
Just like that.
You've got insurance anyway.
Any questions?
Any observations?
Additions?
You can only use objects, you can only do your work.
As soon as you identify or possess, problems will arise.
Can you talk a little about how to remain grounded in meditation and why this might be important?
Well, I think I mentioned it again this morning,
The process of insight, real insight, can only happen when this intuitive intelligence can completely pull itself out of, disidentify with thought.
So thought here includes not only words but images.
Words and images contain our history.
They contain our past experience.
And they are like coloured glasses
that make us see present experience from the view of the past and therefore we're always in a state of comparison or contradiction even if it's a very subtle thing so you meet a friend and you expect them to be like this because of your past experience with your friend if they're not like this then you get upset
when you have some food an apple or something we always take the apple and we're always eating all our history of apples every time you bite that apple it's in comparison with all past apples so it's either not sweet enough or it's just absolutely perfect this is the apple but actually to taste this apple as this apple is you have to get rid of all that now how do we
bring this intelligence back to direct experience of things as they are to understand and see things as they really are, the Buddhist way so you have to bring that intelligence out of thought and you do that by grounding it in your physical feeling experience so if you want to taste the apple, put your attention on your tongue
If you want to see a tree, keep looking at it until, as it were, you're absorbed into the tree, rather than just seeing it as another tree.
So, in the meditation, that's what we're doing.
We're constantly trying to unshackle, unconfuse.
disentangle this intelligence from its identity with thought thought patterns ideas and these things are very subtle so in your breath when you're watching the breath for instance the rising and falling of the abdomen or at the nostrils wherever you're watching it you'll see there's first of all some idea of movement okay
something coming in something coming out there's somewhere a picture in your mind of your of your nose or your abdomen and there's sensation okay now what there is is sensation the idea of it rising and falling and the picture of the of the nose or the of the abdomen are mental constructs okay so by drawing our attention into the breath of sensation
this intelligence begins to let go of that and begins to see sensation as sensation and in this way it's clarifying itself unshackling itself from these thoughts and images as a direct experience now it's not as though we want to get rid of that capacity remember that after the Buddha was awakened
I mean, he spent 40 years.
Yeah, 40 years.
Teaching, walking around, talking, all these miserable people.
And walking up and down and being ordinary.
He wasn't a schizophrenic or anything.
He didn't become a sort of amorphous blob under a tree with a sign, I am fully awake.
I mean, he's an ordinary human being.
He's going around in contact, speaking.
so we don't lose the capacity of thought we just want to gain the capacity of letting it go being able to be directly in contact with experiences as they are not as we think they are or would wish them to be and that's part of the liberation that comes with taxing the passive see
So how do you ground yourself?
You ground yourself in your physical felt experience.
What's an emotion before you give it a name?
That's what you want to find out.
Yeah, any questions there?
you talked about staying with the emotions in meditation is there a time for this in daily life?
sometimes you might find a bit of space to stop just to stop and just as it were contact your present condition but if our awareness if our mindfulness is spacious just generally loose, easy
then as you're talking to somebody, you can be aware of what's happening inside of you.
You can even be aware of the breath on the periphery of your attention.
If you concentrate too much, then you lose it, you see.
But it's a case of feeling at ease and just relaxing into a present situation, you see.
When you walk into a room, just stop for a minute and just receive the room, you see.
when you're with somebody and they're speaking we tend to already be preparing our answer but if we just receive what they're saying and feel what they're saying that's a mode of openness, receiving there's always a little break while the thing switches and we have to respond, you see?
In that way the person really feels that you're really listening to them, you see, rather than trying to defeat them in an argument or something.
So keeping in contact with just our general feeling, you'll see, it gives you a greater sense of control over your life, rather than just be driven by emotional states.
You might be talking to somebody and you got a bit irritated, you see.
But before you walk towards somebody else, you just try and find a little space there to let it dry out a bit.
And then turn with that goodwill, you see, open-heartedness towards the other person.
And you'll find stopping, constantly telling yourself to stop.
It's a really lovely, powerful little word.
One of those four-letter words.
Stop.
good at it you just say stop and the next thing to be done so if you can create that little gap before you do anything you see the intention so at that point you can say to yourself should I be doing this or not?
should I take the hoops?
and
Be careful of this ability that we have of generating further and further like a whirlwind of emotions throughout the day that by the end of the day you feel exhausted.
And you do that again by just stopping and whatever's come up you just let it begin to drain away.
You don't have to wait till it totally goes but begin to drain away.
I think you'll find you reserve a lot of energy.
We use a lot of energy in these emotional states.
Anything else about that?
I consider myself a reasonably happy person.
Rewarding though it is, should I be concerned with the ethics of putting so much effort into being happier?
The purpose of the practice isn't to be happy.
I remember once
when a teacher arrived, and somebody said to him, oh, I'm so happy to see you, Sido.
And Sido said something in Burmese.
And the translator didn't translate it.
And later on, the person who said, I'm so happy to see you, Sido, went to the translator and said, well, you know, like, what did he say?
And he said, well...
He said, I'm not here to make you happy.
I'm here to make you aware.
So our purpose is not to be happy.
Happy is a consequence of the practice.
If you try to make happiness your aim, then you're into a struggle.
Happiness is a consequence.
Peace is a consequence.
You can't peace a situation.
The active ingredients are love, compassion, sympathetic joy.
Yeah?
Death.
What is it that scares so many so much?
Where is thy sting?
Well, this goes back to our problem of identity.
If I think I am this body, and it goes off, and it's going to die, then heck, I'm going to be afraid, aren't I?
It's me.
It's me that dies.
So that identity has, at its deepest root, a real basic fear.
And our problem is that we know we're not real, but we don't accept it.
We know we're not real.
You can walk out of here and that'd be the end of that.
You might get knocked over by a car.
Boom, boom, that's it.
And what happens to your body?
Stick in the box and off it goes.
We know we're not real.
But we insist we are.
And our feeling of reality comes at its most painful when that reality is denied.
And it's denied most obviously by our death.
No wonder so many of us are so scared.
I am.
So that's what we're trying... You could say that the practice of vipassana is a preparation for a peaceful death.
That's what you could say.
one of these phrases you have to die before you die spiritually speaking that means die to this self before you die and Jesus put it another way slightly more joyfully you might say you have to be reborn so to be reborn something must have died
Spiritually speaking, that's what it's talking about.
It's not talking about jumping up and down for Jesus.
Gardening.
You mentioned joy being the way of love and a way of love and being akin to desire for gratification.
the right way for true love of being can you explain please?
with all these virtues that we have they have obviously what's known as in the commentarial literature an obvious enemy so the obvious enemy is love is hate but they always have a subtle enemy to it
So love, as we've said, is attachment.
That means that you want, you need something.
Some of your happiness is dependent on something out there.
That's what attached love is.
In other words, you need to be loved.
It's that sort of feeling.
Loneliness is the need...
For somebody to say they love you, or to express their love, you feel alone.
You don't feel alone, you feel lonely.
And they're not very nice feelings.
In fact, in some cases, it can lead people to despair, even suicide.
But the more you demand that people feed into this loneliness, paradoxically, the more lonely you feel.
Because you know it's a demand, it's not coming from them, it's not natural, it's not given from their heart.
So how do you deal with something like that?
You have to sit with the loneliness, feel it, get in touch with that feeling of not being worthy, self-hatred, whatever comes up with it.
And as it begins to die away, you begin to see these little, little arisings.
It's beginning to transform.
And the transformation is what?
From loneliness to what?
There you go.
Solitude.
Solitude is being perfectly happy beings
your own now if you're perfectly happy being on your own you can see that there's a lot of energy there to love somebody else and you don't expect them you don't need them to fill the hole within your own heart so whenever you find yourself in a position of loving or compassion and you can feel these subtle enemies like grief for somebody
in compassion how does that help?
grieving for somebody compassion should be a joyful emotion you are helping somebody sympathetic joy becomes excited so that it's feeding into your need to be happy all these are very subtle things that happen within us and we get confused and say well this is true love, this is true compassion
But as you know, if I start doing things in order to be happy, going back to this other thing about I'm happy, why should I be more happy?
If I start helping you so that I can be happy, then I get into this classic do-gooder position.
And I define a do-gooder as a person who wants to do you the good they want to do you.
so true love how do you how would you go about establishing true love it's always beginning from where the other person is you're trying to relate to this person so you know where you're coming from right and then you try and put yourself into their position and you do that by asking them what do they want there's a lovely scripture called the I can't remember what it's called now but the Buddha approaches these three
Arahats they're fully liberated beings they're three monks who are living together and he asks them how do you live so peacefully together and Anaruda replies well I say to myself what if I put what I want to do aside and do what the others want to do and in this way we live peacefully now that really only works if you're the person saying the same
you get to be used and abused but you can see the attitude let me just put aside what I want to do for the moment and let me hear what you want to do ask true love that's open then you can buy and do what you want to do so it's a case of putting yourself in somebody else's shoes and that's when you get this feeling of relating real communication with somebody
Joy being the way of love.
Well joy, as I say, joy arises naturally as another type of relationship of rejoicing.
So you're rejoicing in somebody else's happiness.
and what it undermines the subtle enemy of that is of course envy and jealousy where you want what the other person has jealousy you hate them for having it as well these states they arise naturally you know once you get that basic platform right the one of love
Can you discriminate a bit between skilful desire and unskilful desire?
I thought all desire was to be wary of.
It's the English, really.
The word he's trying to translate is tanha.
This tanha is a specific word.
It means the desire that, it's wrong desire.
It's the desire that arises of seeking happiness in the wrong places.
It's not a skillful desire.
There is another word, candor, which is used to mean both good and bad desires.
So for instance, the desire to sit is a good desire, we should develop that.
And all desires that come from these attitudes that we've been talking about, love, compassion, joy, equanimity, they are to be developed.
What we want to be able to discriminate against are those desires that are coming from misunderstanding.
And to try and do that, you'll see translators translating this tanna as craving, which is, you know, there's no English word really, you'd have to say an unskillful desire, put two words together.
Craving is a bit strong.
So all you have to do is, again, this general awareness,
When you see an intention arise, a desire arise, if you're still, you can see, is this wholesome for me or not?
And then what we have to do is build up enough willpower to resist that temptation, if we see it's not good, and just wait for the, you know, just stay with the agony of letting it go.
And when it goes, you're disempowering it all the time, you're disempowering that condition.
And when we see a desire which is good,
and we want to develop it, every time you practice it, you develop that particular conditioning.
That's how it works.
So, you know, in Buddhist psychology, everything begins with a desire, with an intention.
And these intentions produce actions.
Speech, body, mind, thoughts.
Thoughts are actions.
And through these, we create conditionings, habits.
And the whole compendium, the whole collection of habits that we have is our personality.
That's what the personality is.
Our character, personality.
And it's that which is driving us to a destiny.
So it's becoming aware of those things which are driving us to unfortunate destiny and those which are driving us to happy, happy hunting ground.
So it's a case of discriminating.
for ourselves what's good for us and what's not bad and in this way we change this conditioning this is the way we experience life we're changing the way we experience life any comments?
criticism
Have you toured it?
Yeah.
I don't know what's wrong with it.